jessa duggar and her husband ben seawald
will soon have
four kids and counting this is what
we're doing e.t can exclusively reveal
that the couple is expecting their
fourth child together
in a joint statement to e.t jessa and
ben explain quote
after a heartbreaking loss of a baby
last year we're overjoyed to share that
another
little seawalled is on the way nobody
will ever know how wonderful it was
the couple adds that the pregnancy is
going smoothly and they feel so grateful
to be expanding their family
the kids are delighted and we can hardly
wait to welcome this little one
into our arms this summer before
starting their family
jessa and ben got married in 2014 as
seen on the duggar family reality series
19 kids and counting it is my great
privilege to present to you
for the very very first time mr and mrs
benjamin michael seawall
the two have also been very open about
their lives on their spin-off show
counting on documenting their life
raising two boys
spurgeon and henry and their daughter
ivy who they welcomed last year
there are so many doctors and they pile
up
so fast uh we gotta take the trash out
congrats to the seawalls on their
exciting new
[Music]
edition